die chinesische weltraumbehörde hat die
kontrolle über ihr labor tiangong 1
verloren die raumstation bewegt sich
seit märz 2016 unkontrolliert auf die
erde zu jetzt steht endlich genauer fest
wann die stationen auf die erde stürzen
wird doch selbst durch die verbesserten
informationen können immer noch keine
genauen vorhersagen gemacht werden also
wie ist die lage jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
weltraumschrott beschäftigt uns ja immer
wieder aber die anfang ein system
besonders großer brocken übersetzt heißt
die erste chinesische nicht dauerhaft
bemannte raumstation so viel wie
himmlischer palast 8,5 tonnen schwer
etwa so groß wie ein linienbus und
ausgestattet mit einem 14 kubikmeter
großen labor sowie einer kleinen wohn
ecke für die besucher von jcom1 den
letzten jahren hat das raumlabor mehrere
kopplungsmanöver mit chinesischen
raumschiffen der schanze reihe hinter
sich gebracht doch schon 2016
verankerung 1 wohl außer kontrolle
geraten china kann das labor schon seit
märz 2016 nicht mehr steuern die folge
rang eins bewegt sich seitdem
unkontrolliert auf die erde zu im
oktober kreis in die station nach
chinesischen berechnungen wohl noch in
einer mittleren höhe von etwa 3 111
kilometern im mai davor waren es noch
350 kilometer und jetzt sind es nur noch
212 kilometer
regelmäßig gibt es dazu status updates
aus china ab einer höhe von 200
kilometern wird die station deutlich
schneller durch den luftwiderstand
abgebremst und das steht jetzt ganz kurz
bevor jetzt gibt es aktuelle
berechnungen wonach teile der
chinesischen raumstation
schon bald auf die erde stürzen werden
das zeitfenster wird immer enger und es
wird jetzt zwischen dem 30 märz und dem
zweiten april liegen das hat die esa die
europäische weltraumagentur berechnet es
ist nicht das erste mal dass wir uns mit
weltraumschrott beschäftigen müssen weil
er auf kollisionskurs mit der erde ist
vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder
andere von euch 1991 viele bruchstücke
der sowjetischen raumstation zeigen 7
auf argentinien erhöht menschen wurden
nicht verletzt weltraum experten und
expertinnen fordern immer wieder dass
ausgediente stationen und satelliten
direkt im weltraum recycelt werden
anstatt sie weiter mehr oder minder
unkontrolliert auf die erde stürzen zu
lassen
für django 1 gilt dass auf jeden fall
nicht im september 2011 hat china tagung
1 ins all geschickt und jetzt nach
sieben jahren 40 stationen mit ihren 8,5
tonnen gewicht auf die erde eigentlich
sollte sie kontrolliert zum absturz
gebracht werden aber dann brach der
funkkontakt ab die station ist nicht
mehr steuerbar und stürzt jetzt eben
unkontrolliert auf die erde
dabei wird ein
aus teil verglühen aber 30
wahrscheinlich nicht alles was aus
edelstahl oder titan gefertigt ist wird
unweigerlich auf der erde landen zwei
bis drei tonnen dürfen dass im fall von
tiangong 1 seien doch das risiko
getroffen zu werden scheint extrem
gering zu sein zitat die
wahrscheinlichkeit von einem trümmerteil
verletzt zu werden ist so hoch wie die
möglichkeit zwei mal in einem jahr von
einem blitz getroffen zu werden so
holger krag von der esa bislang wurde
noch kein mensch von einem trümmerteil
getroffen es gibt einfach zu viel wasser
und wüsten auf der erde und dort stürzen
jedes jahr achtung 70 bis 80 tonnen
weltraumschrott auf die erde so holger
krag im spiegel war und das finde ich
jetzt echt schon noch eine menge aber
bisher ist es ja noch gut gegangen aber
wo die stationen jetzt runter gehen wird
das kann auch heute noch niemand sagen
sie umrundete die erde in nur 90 minuten
das heißt dass nur wenige minuten
darüber entscheiden wo sie genau
herabstürzt nur eins ist sicher hier in
deutschland sind wir auf keinen fall
betroffen
auf mallorca da könnte sich schon
stürzen denn sie pendelt über die erde
zwischen dem 43 grad südlich und dem 43
grad nördlich und überall zwischen
diesen beiden breitengraden kann die
raumstation abstürzen erst quasi nur
wenige stunden und dann genauer minuten
vor dem absturz kann die genaue stelle
bestimmt werden wobei stelle ist auch so
eine sache es wird damit gerechnet dass
die trümmer in einem 50 kilometer
breiten streifen mit einer länge von bis
zu 1200 kilometern auf die erde prasseln
werden sobald ich etwas weiß wer sich
auf whatsapp schicken da erreichen euch
die nachrichten da sofort und garantiert
wenn er also nichts verpassen wollt dann
endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir auch
vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion von kriegs- und
mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen
oder an abstimmungen teilnehmen und
mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
drauf liegen und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der
genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch draufdrücken
weltraumschrott das ende der raumfahrt
droht ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran